okay can you hear me yeah okay
so hi everybody my name is Lori's crow
I'm a developer advocate at ready slabs
and I live in Italy these are the
languages that I play with the most
social media stuff and a picture of me
doing scuba diving so let's get into the
stuff because I have a lot of things to
say I'm sorry I know it's the last day
the last session but I tried to sell me
that one as much as I could so normally
when people talk about communication
patterns in distributed systems they
mostly talk about inter-service
communication that is service a
communicating to service B that's fine
especially because there are a lot of
things to say on the subject like who is
supposed to do what and who D takes the
share language etc in this session
though I want to zoom in on a single
instance on a single service sorry and
in fact whether you have a hundred micro
services or just one big monolith it
doesn't matter because I want to focus
on what happens inside a single service
so let's zoom in on service a and forget
all about other services when we pick
inside the box of a service we
rediscover that services are actually
made up of different pieces working
together and in this image we have two
instances of the same application with a
load balancer sitting in front of them
and this could be two containers or
could be two processes in case of
processes you wouldn't replicate also
the HTTP server but the idea is that you
are scaling out you have more than one
instance and the details on how you
deploy them don't really matter for the
scope of this presentation so let me
give you one very common example and
while doing so also introduced the
fundamental practice of making
applications stateless so let's say that
your application is an Commerce website
we have a item catalog that sits in the
database and each user has a shopping
cart that they can fill by browsing the
website now where should the shopping
cart leave a reasonable so we'll be
inside the session but there are some
important details to consider first of
all enabling sessions in ethnic core is
very easy it's just two lines of
configuration
here you can see obsession and then your
session to enable the middleware and
with this configuration the session
state is stored in the application
memory and it's connected to a specific
client by a cookie that contains the
session ID similar concept will supply
if you are using Djibouti so the concept
of session is this is an example geared
towards web applications are necessarily
API applications but the concept still
applies so after we are done enabling it
we can access the session object from
the HTTP context of a request and this
session object will be the same across
different requests coming from the same
browser if you google shopping cart ask
net you can find plenty of tutorials
that tell you to do cars this way but
there are a few problems a couple of
problems with this setup the first one
is that if you keep the data in memory
then you bring upon yourself a ton of
operational problems if we have more
than one instance of our application
like we scale out like in the picture
then we will need to route all requests
coming from the same session to the same
instance because otherwise the user will
lose their card or even worse if you
start bouncing requests sometimes they
go to instance one sometimes they go to
instance two they will start having an
inconsistent card which is even worse
so also deploying updates is going to be
more painful because every time your
sort of service sessions containing it
will disappear and you will need to
configure a load balancer to do sticky
sessions which are going to make dynamic
scanning reading annoying if that wasn't
already enough so the fix for this is
simple just move the data inside the
fast memory database and this way you
won't need sticky sessions and more
nowadays you would probably use Redis
for this there are some alternatives
sure and you can also store the cards
inside your main database it's like it's
not legal but yes there are a few
exceptions where you have a huge very
complicated card and you want to keep it
with the rest of your data but generally
speaking cards tend to be something the
session information so you don't want to
persist
like all the stuff and think for example
delivery or other food delivery services
either a user completes an order in a
few minutes or they want to talk so
there is no big reason to persist the
car overnight so in a student car to
enable this ability caching again it's a
couple of lines or a couple of
statements the same more than two lines
but not many are distributed memory
cache to enable disputed caching and add
stock exchange readies cache to
configure readies as a back-end for your
distributed caching Stack Exchange is
part of it method name because asp net
core is using the latest client
developed by them so now you can use the
session object just as you did before
but we do have the benefit that the
session will now be accessible from all
application instances so no more sticky
sessions if you remember i mentioned two
problems the first one we just solved by
moving in sessions to Redis but there
the second ones to standing and that is
in a snit court sessions or browser
sessions not user sessions so this means
that if we were to save the card the
card state directly in the session
object the same user would see two
different cards when logged in from two
different devices normally think you
would want your users to be able to
continue building their order once they
get home and switch device maybe from a
phone to PC or or tablet again the fix
not is a no particularly involved all we
need to do is to keep inside the session
or reference to the user ID and then use
that information to store and load card
data from the I distributed cache
interface in this code I'm injecting an
I distributed cache into my controller
and then I'm able to access it notice
that the cache is not session specific
like HTTP contest doc dot session was so
you need to specify in the key name
whose card you are trying to fetch so
now we have the card that is user
session specific and not even not
browser session specific anymore now
users can are able to use different
devices to continue built-in order and
they won't experience any service
degradation if you are scanning
dynamically in the meantime so
congratulations
this is how you set up dissipated
caching in your system it's really just
a configuration option basically so
before we move on to the next subject I
just want to encourage you to read the
official documentation to see well as
its needed to do a proper production
deployment and also some of the generic
methods that I was using of course like
get card our extension methods that you
are supposed to write and this
documentation explains you how to do it
it's mostly about serialization so okay
we spent enough time talking about
sessions and I won I think it was
important to talk a little about
sessions because everybody has to deal
with those problems and also because
sessions are in caching our real
coordination problems but there's an
industry we understand them fairly well
and when a problem is well understood
then you get an easy configuration
option in your framework but not every
problem that we encounter is just as
easy so let's talk about the kind of
problems for which you don't find a
configuration option in the dotnet core
as I mention in the beginning I think we
don't give enough love to inter service
coordination problems and as a
consequence it's not trivial to the host
pace of patterns and problems there we
can encounter in this scenario for this
reason I'd like to mention a couple of
more examples to help us muscles help us
map the space a little bit I don't want
to get too much into the details of next
one because it's a very deep rabbit hole
but I mentioned the main problems
associated with it and there is live
chat applications IRC style I hope
everybody here has a chance to try or
see in the past or more recently because
it's still alive I'm using it and I'm
not alone but just make it clear this is
what iris looks like it's just text and
messages are not persisted on server
because you're supposed to see only
messages sent while you were online and
connected these connections are
organizing channels so you connect to a
server join a channel or create a new
one or drink more than one and then you
are able to chat with other people in
the same channels as you are so going
back to the contents of our service box
if our application is now chat server so
we're not doing e-commerce and
now we repeat it if we scale down like
in the picture how do we make messages
sent to one instance reach other
instances in the Commerce example there
was no communication between users so we
could just be simply distribute requests
across multiple instances and that was
it we just needed to take care of the
shared State but now if a user is
connected to instance one and another
one is connected to instance two and
they are in the same Channel how do we
make them communicate I might say why
don't we just distribute channels among
different instances and have clients
make multiple connections if they want
to join multiple channels so you could
say if you want to connect two channels
a and B you have to connect two instance
one if you want to join channels C and D
you have to connect instance two but
guess what I'm doing these introduces a
lot of operational problems because now
you must be able to address individual
instances and either your clients know
how to do this all your love manager
knows how to route connections correctly
and it's the session situation all over
again but with the only difference that
were before we needed sticky sessions
now we need some other kind of routing
policy based on the channel name and
like before if you should download an
instance you don't just disconnect a few
users you're going to completely kill a
few channels which is going to make it
hard to do dynamic scaling and if you
think about it in this case probably
your clients are going to hold
long-running connections to your
services something like WebSockets it's
a chat application of the role and so
you're going to disconnect somebody
while doing dynamic and I'm scaling this
has to happen but one thing is
disconnect a few people for a moment
another thing is to kill an inter
channel completely and you cannot even
design a graceful shutdown procedure for
this for this configuration for this
case because to do graceful shutdown you
would need to migrate channel from an
instant from the instance that you're
shutting down to another one and the
only way to do that is we have some kind
of coordination between two instances
which is what we were trying to avoid in
the beginning so we're back to square
one actually square zero so in the
session situations by moving
sessions to a distribute the cash we
were able to remove a lot of internal
tension in the system and in this other
example being able to connect to any
channel from any instance has the same
effect because it is what allows us to
treat the instances as cattle not as
pets we don't want to have to address
instances individually so what we want
is a way to keep a connection up in
between all instances and when one
receives a new message it can then
broadcast it to all other instances in
other words we want to pub sub system
now it might surprise you but there
aren't that many pub sub implementations
out there
pure pops up and more often not one you
will find our queue implementations
message queue implementations that also
support pops up as a routing scheme
which is fine in general but it becomes
unsustainable when you want both high
throughput and low latency like in the
case of a real-time chat application
pubert sub is a synchronous
fire-and-forget communication pattern
where producers publish messages on a
channel and all the consumers subscribe
to the channel receiving a message but
because it's fire-and-forget there are
no acknowledgments no acts and because
it's synchronous there is no persistence
so if you if your client loses its
connection or NASA just broadcasted in
the meantime will be lost for that
client
all these things quite limiting but the
truth is that when this is all you need
every other extra feature will
potentially introduce leh and complexity
with no benefit for you so during qsg
are two very cool socket libraries for
implementing pub/sub and a few other
messaging patterns they are also
proculus libraries meaning that
participants must know how to connect to
each other directly they're very cool
there are also very low levels or they
are used to basically build networking
tools ready pop sub is a brokered
version of pub/sub so you brought
readies itself acts as the brokers or
every participant connected to Redis and
then ready to us the message routing and
I can show you how to use it it's very
simple see they can do that correctly so
first of all I have to launch ready
server you can see
from the cool graphic that it's running
also I can show your best practice for
demonizing processes it is so ready CLI
is the command-line client for I this
I'm gonna launch two instances and I'm
gonna subscribe to channel in one and
that is a simple as sub scribe to maybe
ashtag readies the ashtag it's not
mandatory I'm just using it because we
were talking about IRC IRC channel start
with a hashtag outside however you want
to call it so now this client is
connected to pub/sub and subscribe to
the channel Redis so in this order
client I can simply publish channel
hashtag Reddy's message hello the moment
is in the message the other channel the
other client receives it say it very
simple you can also do something more
interesting there is also I recommend
not clear but another one called the
SUBSCRIBE and I can P subscribe the P
stands for pattern I can pattern
subscribe to every channel the start
with bound R so every channel starts
with R now if I send a message to Redis
a receive it if I send a message to read
it I receive it but if I'm man if the
message is sent to NDC I don't receive
it because it doesn't match the pattern
very simple and keep in mind pattern
subscribing to a pattern it's not
allocating extra my or is not creating
topics there is not
none of this stuff channel names in in
in pure pops up there are just simple
strings to that the system pattern
matches to decide the routing there is
no resource allocation behind this
okay going back to the presentation so
in the case of our chat application then
pub/sub is exactly what the application
needs in the sense of a sub is IRC just
for applications and not for humans and
I'm sure that there are many
applications silently screaming the need
if your first stop for solving this went
to Kafka or unserved
our enterprise service bus like in
service bus or something else just you
read this blog posted abroad for our
technical blog in it I discussed the
differences between 0 mq rabid Kafka and
a few others and I talked about which
problem is best solved by each and I
also recommend it if you want to know
more about the difference between pure
pub/sub and a system that is something
else that also supports pub/sub is a
routing scheme because the differences
are not real
so even streams and ESPs are important
fundamental communication mechanisms
between different services but my point
is that top sub is equally important
when coordinating instances of the same
server of the same service and it's
assumed that we don't spend enough time
talking about it so let me show you
another example that highlights how
useful humble pub/sub can be we covered
two extremes of the space and my next
example is going to be closer to
sessions the concept is not new but I
wanted to give it a call I wanted to
give a cool name to my take on solving
it so I called it memory oak so what
some amount of time why should you care
well there is a problem called cache
stampede that you might have heard of
and it's something that happens when a
service is under heavy load and there is
a cache miss on a popular radio so
normally on a cache miss you generate an
updated version of the missing value and
put it back in the cache the problem is
that generating that value is not
mediate and in the meantime another
instance could be trying to do the same
thing resulting in duplicate work so if
you look at the picture you can see and
see if I can use my mouse oh yeah I can
so you can see that this instance the
one right on the Redis is trying to get
through from Redis
oops trying to get who from red this
doesn't find it then goes on the
database retreats the value and saves it
back into Redis but in the meantime
there's a second instance that is also
trying to find four credits doesn't find
it and then it does the same thing and
this work is completely useless it's
just duplicate work so this is a cache
stampede and under heavy load this
behavior makes things got worse because
you are bound to have more and more
requests piling up for popular values
and popular missing values and this is
going to cause more to placate work and
if you're eating your database you're
going to even slow down more producing
that value which is going to enlarge
make it wider your Stampede window so
it's a vicious cycle and how do we break
out of it there are a few different ways
to mitigate this problem some require
good statistical knowledge of your
domain so I'll skip them because they
are too specific in a way and this
leaves us with everybody's most dreaded
part of concurrency locks by one you may
not well you might not like them they're
the diet of choice for for philosophers
out of five so they're not that bad but
all jokes aside locks can be useful when
used with persimmony so by protecting
each value with a lock we ensure that
only one process can hit database and
that completely prevents the stampede so
our skin at that point would be I tried
to search for full-on righties I don't
find it so before going blindly
hitting it on to the database I try to
acquire a lock for foo if I and I only
go on to the database if I cry now if I
if I can acquire that lock so ok
this sounds simple on paper a
concurrence is never easy right so let
me show you how to do locks with trellis
so ready this is a key value store right
there are a few different data types the
simple one is our strings of course so I
can set swing I can set foo - hello
these crates full I can get then fool if
I get foo I get my hello back super easy
I can also delete it okay
I can also do something more I can do
set lock call okay lock column foo -
right but I can say I want to set it
only if the key does not exist before
because otherwise it would override the
existing key so with this command I get
to play the first time but let's say I
try again and instead of hi I try Xiao
this time I don't get ok I get Neil and
if I try to get full sorry lock column I
get high I don't get chow because the NX
option not existing makes the command
work only if the key does not exist yet
this is enough to make a lock but not
enough because in a distributed system a
lock that never expires is useless
because something is going to blow up
and acquire the lock forever otherwise
so you need a locks that expire over
time and that's as simple as adding
another option so I can delete this
weird lock
and now I can create a lock listen let's
start with the chattel value and I
create it with an expired
so I can expire it after five seconds so
now I create the value I can get it but
after five seconds the key doesn't exist
anymore and I can get it anymore so the
key word the block was released this is
actually a lease unlock but this is what
it's useful to have so very simple it's
one command two options you can also
specify the expire in more than just
seconds can be more precise than that
but that's easier to present so when I'm
back to our sample code this becomes
this the value is probably best if it's
a unique ID or something like this
because then you can know if that lock
knowing that the lock exists doesn't
tell you if you are the one holding it
or not so a unique value helps you
it's called financing had to understand
that and avoid doing work about doing
like a right try this if you're not the
one holding a lock anymore so now what
do we do if we don't quire the lock well
in that case there it means that there
is somebody that somebody else that's
producing the value and if only there
was a way to get notified when they're
done right and if you think about it
possibly is exactly what we need in that
situation we just want a live
notification we don't want to be woken
up at 5:00 because there's our hard
drives are filled with undelivered
messages it's only something useful
while the application is still alive the
instance is still alive so for the sake
of completeness if we were able to
acquire the lock we should also then
publish on pub/sub that we are done so
this is a more complete version of that
code so you may now ask okay how much am
i over simplifying this code well I'm
not over simplifying that much there are
only two things that I'm not showing one
is time of handling because okay the
local expires that's cool but you cannot
stay forever waiting on pub/sub for a
notification that it's never going to
come
potentially so you need to timeout out
of that the second one is that you need
to check for the key again inside radius
after you subscribe let me show you this
a little bit better so the whole scheme
is if I get foo I try to get food from
readies I find it I'm done if I don't
find it I thought to occur the lock if I
can't acquire the lock then I subscribe
but between when I try to get foo and
when I subscribed there is a small
window in which the other process might
have finished producing foo and sent out
an application and it would miss it
because I'm not yet subscribed so after
you subscribe we need to get full again
to make sure to basically close that
window that's one way of something it
also alternative ways so oh sorry
skipping one part so basically what my
implementation does is this all you need
to do is provide do work in this part
here your function that does produce the
work and inside your fraction you can do
whatever you want you don't you are not
constrained to only take values out of a
database you could produce them in other
ways you could run our file store it on
a CDN and just then put a link inside
radius as example and this brings me why
I call it memory Ock because it's
memorization in a distributed context so
it requires locking memorization was
locking if you never heard of
memorization which is it's not the type
it's memorization not memorization you
can search for it on Wikipedia long
story short it's the concept of caching
function calls and so instead you run a
function once and then you save that out
put inside a dictionary and use the
input that you give to that function as
the key so the next time somebody is
given the same input to your function
you just return the cash value from a
dictionary instead of running the
function again
I'm slightly abusing the term because
usually this is a mathematical concept
that applies to pure functions here's
nothing exactly the same but in practice
can work you can use the same concept to
apply caching to normal functions
so the code is available on github
Christoph - Nettie is my account on
github and the repository is called
readies - Malik I have two
implementations up there one is a shift
Sharpe implementation one is a go
implementation it's interesting to look
at the two implementations and see how
concurrency is handled differently
between different in different
ecosystems and also they can
interoperate so you can have go be
producing a value and in the meantime
have a few c-sharp instances waiting for
the gunk shown to complete because they
are gonna communicate through pub/sub
and so they stick to the language the
only thing you have to be careful about
is using a sane serious sterilization
protocol because you will need to
serialize and deserialize stuff from
both languages so I want to say a couple
of words about Redis this is the 2019
stack overflow survey and like last year
right this has been voted the most loved
database and if you've never heard about
Reddy's or you've only used it for
caching you might ask yourself why is
that is it because it's fast a lot of
people are selling religious fast but I
don't think that's the case I think it's
because it helps you solve these types
of coordination problems in easy with
ease with simplicity and because it's
fast Redis is all about simplicity which
keep in mind doesn't mean making things
easy it means making things not more
complicated than they have to be even
when you're doing not easy things like
concurrency Redis gives you small
orthogonal pieces then you then compose
together to make a perfect felishj
solution for your use case and then from
that you get speed maintainability a
reliability or all the good stuff also
going back to our spectrum that I were
showing of coordination problems inside
a single service you can see that there
is a big hole in there so what's in it
the answer is I have no idea I don't
know I think we don't talk enough about
this stuff and I yeah I can come up with
a couple more examples
in my previous jobs and probably there's
a piece of literature out there that has
a few more but there are not
configuration options in a framework and
you might have seen some of these
situations and maybe not recognized it
one thing that I noticed is that when
you don't get coordination right you end
up with operational problems so if you
think about past systems that you worked
on that had that were nasty to operate
and maybe that was because coordination
within the service was not handled
correctly so if you can think of some
let me know because I would love to give
an updated version of this presentation
where I just enumerate the problems and
the relative configuration option in a
slot net that would be nice to have so
before I show you the code quick
commercial break I work for a company
called Redis labs we are a company of
people that love Redis and we also work
class right these experts bring each
statement
I know but while we employ the creative
readies and tourettes
so got to shoot the town for something
but it's not just in everybody in Redis
Labs has a ton of experience with Redis
and we're also hiring so if you love
readies let me know you don't have to be
a world-class expert don't worry because
we can make one out of you what do we do
we developed Redis enterprise and also
if you read these modules that work also
on open source Redis and Redis
Enterprise is basically readies +
enterprise stuff on top and you can have
it as a software and run it yourself on
communities which are flavor you like or
you can't have world-class experts run
it for you as a service dbaas
or in your V PC at a bless DCP is your
name it you can have it ok let's go on
to code and demo this part I didn't
rehearse so bear with me I'll try to do
my best I can see that the resolution is
even better than I anticipated so I can
zoom in a little bit to make it easier
for you maybe
yes ok so this is a
controller I just set up a very basic
project with the.net command line tool
and this is just a very simple query
controller I can show you the interface
of my radius numeric class so different
to what I showed in the slides I'm just
doing one extra thing which is I'm
giving a name space to our items inside
radius named sizes are cool so this
allows you to deal with different
objects with ease so the naming scheme
becomes then I created here already
smell ugh to cache query object so in
this example I'm cashing query object so
I create a radius by malach I say that
this the tag for this type of objects is
query so the naming scheme becomes query
column foo is the key that will all the
value query - lock solid slash lock
column foo is the name of the lock key
and query slash not if is the name of
the notification channel as you can see
the usage interface is very simple you
define timeout for your request and then
just invoke get resource you give it a
resource ID how long should the request
wait before time going in timeout and
you supply a function inside your
function you generate your value so in
this case real example would be going on
to the database and faction the query
set but here I'm just gonna sleep to
simulate the type of work and in the end
your function has to return what you
want to cash in try this so what the
value is and for how long that value
should be cached before expiring I can
show you this running so I can launch
the project
okay I'm also using curl to great
request for Aldo deathcore app I'm using
the - key up - K option because I
haven't stopped properly HTTP luckily I
have no certificates so that allows me
to use it nevertheless so here I'm
calling query simple foo so pretty
simple - is is this handler here that I
was showing you before query simple
let's see what happens I'm gonna launch
it at the same time
what kind at the same time from both
consoles so you will see that calling it
twice he's gonna cause working hard to
show up only once and they will both
return the value at the same time that
comments that log line is something I
defined in here so this function only
executes once one of the two clients go
through lock executed job the other one
was just waiting on box up extremely
simple there's another example which is
the external controller the external
controller uses get externally managed
resource and the idea is that maybe in
your handler you don't you're not the
one that is going to produce the value
maybe you have an external executable
that is going to produce it something
like PDF generating library for example
and so here I'm just invoking the
command which in in this case it's a
Python script that it's gonna run a
stammer
so one of those tools of natural
language processing that gives you the
radix of a word remove suffixes and and
that's it I don't even here I'm not even
waiting for it to complete executing I
don't care because that executable is
going to communicate with the rest of
the system through pops up so let me
show you the script is actually here and
stammer dot P I is just Python script
that uses the a and ldk stammer
produces the stem of input value and
uses the appropriate scheme to set up
set the key with the value and produce a
notification on pops up so let me try to
run this in this case it's e XD - C keep
forgetting standard okay cool
next stammer singing I'm gonna choose
singing as a word I don't do the same
here e XD
actually anyway I'm gonna do it twice
whatever again
steamer shows up only once in or the log
line and you can see that both got the
result from a Python script and it's
very easy to integrate this stuff
because the only integration surface is
one client library into commands
subscribe and publish let me show you
what I do in practice inside my
implementation so the go implementation
is a full-fledged galang module so you
can actually import it if you're using a
new version of go I haven't done all the
work on the necessary work to do it also
in c-sharp because also because in the
shop probably to make this useful you
would need to do all the end to get the
encapsulation right I'm lazy so I I just
did the minimal amount of work to show
what what the actual algorithm is so let
me start with the main body of our
function which is get resource which is
the implementation that works behind the
scenes under behind a few public
interfaces so first we and it's one one
slides almost so first we check if the
resource available on Redis if we find
it we return immediately if you don't
find it then we try to acquire the lock
if we get the lock then we do the job
the difference is that if it's an
externally managed job so we just read
invoke an external process and that
process is gonna do the publishing then
we don't do anything otherwise if it's a
c-sharp function like the first example
that I showed you then we take the
result from that function this is our
this is our do work function that you
passed in as an input as a anonymous
function then we run it take the value
and store it inside radius respecting
the TPL the time to leave that you
defined for it and that's pretty much it
for that case in case we don't find we
don't acquire the lock we can't acquire
so then we have to subscribe to pop sub
and I'm doing this with this setup
notification function these thing here
things get a bit more involved as I will
show you later but the main end time of
handling again very simple I create a
time out test and then I await on both
the time out task and the time out and
the task that should come back with a
result from the identification the first
one that returns is the one that is
gonna decide what happens with this
method so if it's time out we're gonna
throw out them at a session if it's not
a time out we just return the value and
we're done so it has to be all a sink
await because you can return the value
immediately if you run the function if
you are the one producing the value but
if you're not the one producing the
value of course you need a task or
something along those lines so set up a
notification is a bit more involved
because we are not so using the status
change client if you just call subscribe
ten times you will instantiate 10
connections there and each is going to
subscribe to one channel and you don't
want to do that you want one connection
that subscribes multiple channels in
this case I'm subscribing with a pattern
so I'm subscribing to all resources of
the type that are handled by by this
controller so with the query type this
would subscribe to all channels that
start with query selection not've so
internally I'm gonna basically multiplex
that connection I'm gonna keep in memory
dictionary that contains for each
channel a list of tasks that are
awaiting for a notification coming for
the in that channel so there is a there
is a dictionary then that is shared I
can show it on top when I see it this is
a concurrent dictionary it has to be
concurrent dictionary because you could
schedule all of this function in
different threads
you could undo concurrency however you
want on while calling the functions so
we need to ensure that we don't do
something
wrong by touching by having two threads
touching the same dictionary at the same
time unless it's a concurrent dictionary
and concurrently Chinese basically give
you this add or update function which is
interesting because basically you give
it the key that you want to block create
or change inside your dictionary and
then you give it a lambda function in
which you do the you apply the change
that you want it's very easy then it's a
one-liner and this way and completely
avoiding any kind of weird coordination
weird concurrency problem within c-sharp
so after I subscribe to the notification
then I check again on the database if
the key is available as I told you
before because I there is that small
window that would otherwise make this
algorithm wrong let me show you where I
set up the the pub/sub subscription here
I'm creating a Redis channel I'm telling
to the client that it's a pattern
Channel so the star should not be taken
literally like if you use subscribe and
a star not be subscribed then the star
will have a literal meaning will not
have the pattern meaning the usual
pattern meaning meaning any type any
character after me after the previous
one so when I subscribe I just give it a
handler function and that handler
function has to basically do only one
thing
receive and I receive a message the
message will contain in it you will
receive then to which channel the
message was sent because you subscribe
to a pattern so you have to know which
precise channel the message was sent to
and then the actual message body and
here all I'm doing is trying to remove
that key in order to obtain a wait list
and then I'm just gonna iterate over the
wait list and resolve all tests within
it one other interesting thing is
that usually if you just create a normal
tasks tasks are supposed to be resolved
by functions that do normally IO in this
case we are treating a special type of
task that is manually triggered by us at
a later stage here we're triggering it
but let me show you where I instantiate
it here I'm creating a task completion
source which is the type of task that
then exposes a method to manually
trigger it by using try set result
there's also a few methods to fail it
and do all the normal stuff that you
expect from from tasks so before I
include the top let me show you one last
example it's a bit corny but I took the
time to write it and I wanted to show it
I created another handler which contains
as I said a corny joke so text slash
joke so take a look at what happens in
the dotnet run console so the great nut
net current time is speaking to us and
it's asking us to determine if one is a
prime number or not so it's up to us to
find that solution I'll give you a
moment to think about this in the
meantime I'm gonna open Redis already
awry so it is up to us raise your hand
if you think that one is not a prime
number if it is if you don't care okay a
few no to sorry
is it like it's a yes well let's see so
I have to set ext dot one two yes and
then publish to X
t / not if con 1 yes do we make it in
time yes we did and at the end of the
day or current time doesn't even care
but this is to showcase that the
integration surface is so small that I
can do it in a client come online easily
so that's that's it thank you very much
for listening
[Applause]
sure
so I'm subscribing for the channel would
be a cleanup procedure that you do when
you are shutting down your service
basically or when you are destroying the
instance of a specific radius memo LOC
object in general you don't subscribe to
the single one to the single channel
because you are subscribed to a pattern
so you want to get all notifications
coming to the red pattern and the
SUBSCRIBE and subscribe in a sense I'm
doing it manually inside my handler by
removing from the dictionary object the
list of colors of cortines whatever you
want to call them frames waiting for a
notification on that channel so that's
in a way my unsubscription that happens
are there any other questions since not
so then thank you very much